[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants au froid ce que tu
es chic ce soir nounours patron je suis
chute parce que je vais voir des enfants
très propre mon petit cornichons devient
un petit garçon très élégant et très
soigneux alors moi aussi je soigne ma
présentation vous ne voudriez pas l'euro
c'est mon échelle pas que je veux paris
je ne veux pas salir mais pas tous voilà
le nours
hop ça va très bien merci
pow pow pow pow pow pow pow pow pow pow
wow vous avez compté que jusqu'à 3 on ne
peut pas jouer aux dés l'eau mois les
deux c'est mon jeu préféré
mais oui
donna beau chapeau les chick notre nos
noces oui bah oui il me plaît beaucoup
de chapeaux oui j'y tiens juliette a
vient voir le beau chapeau
[Musique]
non je garde mon chapeau tiens je te les
changes
mais apple pie je te les donne tout
nounours et une bonne ton chapeau
oui ou non
son bel cbi non je ne veux pas tiens
alors
voilà magit non je veux garder mon
chapeau
juliette a plus une coquine
le second chapeau attend juilletà attend
matin
nous nous
jetons donne la toupine
sadoudi
acceptent nos fruits cornichons je
t'aime bien j'aime bien ta putin mais je
ne te donnerai pas mon chapeau
juliette à 20 sur ton arbre et vous oui
or vouloir me prendre mon post apo grand
bain
ne fâchent pas de nous il veut pas de le
prendre dix veulent échanger c'est
pareil mon chapeau ce cas
bonne nuit les enfants
point de nuit mans
où il dut encore porte je suis prêt
julietta je dors près des
malades la peine tu ceux
là là ce n'est rien mais juliette a
[Musique]
qui lui a pas laissé prendre tous à pau
je ne laisserai jamais prendre mon
pauvre chapeau ça nous alors
[Musique]
alors alors et qu'est ce qui lie à
nounours tu as l'air pressé et de
mauvaise humeur sauvons loup patron
cette coquine de juliette à est capable
de venir me prendre mon chapeau partons
vite bonne nuit les enfants fait deux
tours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]